[Music]
hello everyone and welcome back to the
Rotten Tomatoes is wrong podcast I am
your host Mark Ellis flying solo today
although do ducks really fly or do they
just kind of flap their wings and then
hope they land on a pond soon I am still
in the uh Sand Pond we'll say of Las
Vegas Nevada where I've been working
um for quite some time it feels like
according to this show anyway but thanks
to the good Folks at Brad Garrett's
Comedy Club having a great week in Las
Vegas and now it might be the best hour
of my Las Vegas trip not because I'm
gambling not because I'm doing stand up
but because I'm talking to one of my
good buddies about a film franchise that
is so beloved that is just so celebrated
it came out in the 90s it could have
easily been an afterthought but no Not
only was it a good movie it spawned a
film franchise which is rare in the
sports movie world and even rare it
spawned an actual team that is in the
professional ranks if you don't don't
know what movie franchise we're talking
about yet and you didn't happen to take
a look at this podcast before you
clicked on it you are watching slash
listening to the Rotten Tomatoes is
wrong episode of The Mighty Ducks
Trilogy all three Mighty Ducks movies
which one is the mightiest is it the
Mighty Ducks from 1992 21 rotten can you
believe that is your inner child okay
did you hear me 21
rotten on the Tomato Meter does have a
65 audience score which is the only
freshness we're getting from any one of
these three movies according to our
beloved metrics so D2 the Mighty Ducks
1994 is also 21 rotten 59 audience score
and then D3 from 1996 is 20 rotten with
a 45 audience score and so we're talking
about the Ducks movies because you have
the Mighty Ducks game changers which is
the TV show season two is about to drop
later on this month and we also have a
bunch of fans that have been emailing us
they've been begging they've been
tagging us on social media saying you
need to talk about the Mighty Ducks so
thank you to our fresh ketchup crew for
that support and even my co-host who
can't be here today Jaclyn Coley and I
often go back to this movie just because
it's just one of those films that sticks
in your childhood and it just stays with
you until you become a tall adult uh
let's talk to Robert drost he's going to
talk to us rather because he sent us an
email RT is wrong at rottentomatoes.com
and he says I want you guys to focus on
the True Underdog of the sports film
world you know what I'm talking about
the only Sports film that's found in
actual professional sports franchise I
want you guys to talk about the Mighty
Ducks there's nothing better than
watching those kids come out with a
goaltender net and the famous Flying V I
hope you take these critics to task for
knocking on this amazing Sports classic
that made me never underestimate the
alcoholic lawyer Who quote doesn't like
hockey and hates kids because you never
know he could just turn out to become a
hockey legend for decades to come quack
quack quack quack quack thank you Robert
for that email and for the inspiration
to do this episode today with one of my
dear friends you all know him from his
social media presence uh the Swaggy
blurred is where you can find him across
all social media platforms and you can
check him out weekly talking all things
comic book movies on capes and cows as
part of the big thing show he is Winston
hey Marshall and if you're watching the
show you can see us at Winston actually
has a Mighty Ducks jersey on so I
imagine this franchise means a little
something to you good sir uh well first
of all let me let me clarify this this
is not the Mighty Ducks this is the
mighty drunks and and when I and when I
say that I say that in the sense that my
adult kickball team we we do uh you know
their their tournaments throughout the
uh the country
we just go around and just quack it at
people are instead of full quacks our
our chant is quack quack chug chug
that's the way we get drunk that's how
much this movie has influenced Our Lives
is that we had to find a proper way to
to grow it up and continue the Legacy a
real game changer if you will it's
almost like y'all are turning into coach
Gordon Bombay before he inherited the
Mighty Ducks when he was just out but he
was just a lawyer when he was just a
crappy lawyer that nobody cared about
that would do anything to win win win
win win win win win win
before he learned his lesson you know
this is why you're the perfect guest for
this episode because I forgot not only
does Winston love playing kickball he
also plays dodgeball professionally so
you kind of play all these like little
kids sports that we just thought we'd
grow out of once we no longer had to go
to gym class but you're keeping the gym
sports like the the rainy day hey
coaches got to let us do something let's
do Dodge well let's do kickball you're
keeping that alive into adulthood excuse
me all sports are little kids sports
okay basketball I'm gonna put a little
round thing in a hoop a football I'ma
throw this little ball as far as I can
and see if you can go and catch it don't
don't do this Mark Ellis just because
you like to sit around and watch some
crappy team called the Washington
commanders embarrass themselves 17 weeks
out of the year because Lord knows you
don't make it past week 17 doesn't mean
you need to come for me in my sports sir
please I just want to be relevant at
Thanksgiving that's all I care about
with the commanders and uh well we'll
see the season is still young for both
Cowboys fan Winston and myself so
Winston the one thing that we can agree
on I think is our favorite of the three
Mighty Ducks movies I believe but that's
what we're doing today we're gonna rank
these so do you feel like overall Rotten
Tomatoes Miss The Mark with the Mighty
Ducks franchise again 21 rotten for the
first two 20 for part three is Rotten
Tomatoes wrong about the mighty us
Mark normally in this episode I just
come through you'll hear me the outline
of what we're going to talk about and we
just get into it but today I brought me
some facts and figgles because
I was so appalled to hear how low the
mighty dunks Mighty dunks oh Lord maybe
I am a mighty drunk today the Mighty
Ducks films have been just lambasted so
let me give you some uh some facts and
figgles Space Jam
43 Rotten I'm not talking about a new
Legacy I'm talking about the OG one of
the greatest sports kids movies of all
time how dare you
The Little Rascals
Misfit group of kids that just want to
tell girls to go away and ride in the
pinewood derby 23 percent
and yet somehow The Goonies which is
just as goofy as all the rest of these
films had 73 fresh I just
I am appalled you have a Flying V a
knuckle puck the bash Brothers and
you're gonna give me 21 absolutely not
both of the first two films deserve to
be in the pantheon Super Fresh all that
kind of stuff but we all have an averman
that we have in our lives you know and
so sometimes
sometimes you don't end your Trilogy try
it quite as strong and
that one could stay rotten we're fine
with them the first two how dare you
yeah you know it's interesting thinking
about the first two and how we finally
remember those and then there's like oh
yeah then they also did D3 and so there
might be a wanted demarcation between
two and three they maybe didn't close
the trilogy as well as well as of Lord
of the Rings or Star Wars would be used
to but we're gonna hear what the critics
were saying at the time of the mighty
ducks's release in all three different
years 92 94 and 96. uh I feel like
rotten tomatoes is wrong I don't feel as
strongly as Winston does let's get a
word from those critics back then with
our buddy Tim Ryan our expert review
curation manager here at Rotten Tomatoes
for his segment two minutes with Tim
with him I spent way too much time
preparing for this podcast trying to
figure out how many real-life sports
teams were named after movies there's an
excellent chance that I'm totally
missing something so let me apologize
beforehand for any omissions there are a
few teams with names that were inspired
by elements of movies and TV shows the
Toronto Raptors basketball team was not
named after Jurassic Park obviously but
the movie certainly inspired the name
since Velociraptors were all the rage
back in 1993 and the area where fans
gather outside the stadium is called
Jurassic Park in a classic episode of
The Simpsons the Springfield Isotopes
are planning to move to Albuquerque
before Homer stages a one-man protest
this inspired the name of the
Albuquerque Isotopes the Triple A
affiliate of the Colorado Rockies
although again the team is not called
The Simpsons one of the rare potentials
I could find was in a guardian article
that claims that an Argentinian soccer
team club sportivo Ben Hur was so named
because its Founders were inspired after
seeing the movie Ben Hur however the
original movie came out 1925 and the
team was founded in 1940 so maybe I
couldn't find much more about them on
the Internet that was in English
and just a side note Bull Durham is
named after the Durham Bulls not the
other way around there is one team that
was absolutely named after a movie
Disney created both the Mighty Ducks the
movie in 1992 and in 1993 the Mighty
Ducks of Anaheim a real
honest-to-goodness NHL team and they
kept the name until 2005. now they're
just the Anaheim Ducks
okay so the movies they made three of
them they're about a brand of Scrappy
Misfits and underdogs who come together
to become winners critics thought they
were mediocre but a substantial number
of kids of a certain age love them the
Mighty Ducks from 1992 is rotten to 21
on the Tomato Meter but it has a 65
audience score D2 the Mighty Ducks from
1994 is also rotten to 21 and it has a
59 audience score and D3 the Mighty
Ducks from 1996 is rotten at 20 and it
has a 45 audience score in a fresh
review of the original Malcolm Johnson
of the Hartford current called it a
decent enough kids picture with some
laughs and the always required Sports
element heart however in a rotten review
for D2 Malcolm Johnson of the Hartford
Courant wrote where the Mighty Ducks
reworked a familiar plot with some
feeling its follow-up seems to have
nothing on its mind other than cashing
in on the success of the original but
wait they also made a series The Mighty
Ducks game changers from 2021 is
certified fresh at 87 percent and it has
a 77 audience score so that's the Mighty
Ducks extended universe and even though
I don't really follow hockey I'd be
remiss if I didn't mention that the
Anaheim Ducks kick off the 2022-23
season on October 12th where they host
the Seattle Kraken a team whose name was
inspired at least in part by Clash of
the Titans back to you folks that might
be the best two minutes with Tim I've
ever heard they're always good I know
Winston and I always look forward to
listening to him when he's on the show
that might have been the best one of all
time Winston but I have to point out
first of all my brother lives up near
Seattle and so I own a Seattle Kraken
Jersey so uh we we definitely need to
hang on October 12th and we need to get
down to Anaheim to that game but I also
would would pick a bone here with Tim
Ryan because I feel like without the
movie franchise the Nashville NHL team
known as the Predators would not would
build that because you really don't want
to name your team Predators unless
there's a cool alien to back it up am I
right yeah but isn't isn't their logo
maybe I haven't seen in a while I can
Google it isn't their logo like a Bobcat
of some sort with like some with like
some saber tooth fangs I believe it's
more like a jungle cat but again you're
you're the Predator changed the game the
the name Predator I think will forever
be synonymous at least uh partially with
the alien as opposed to the ones that
you know uh Chris Hanson used to catch
on I mean if we could just add like a
couple little just like like that would
work you know I I feel like that would
up the team they might start winning
championships they got close one time
the Mighty Ducks did win a championship
and we'll talk about that and I guess
we'll get into some movie chat as well
hit the music Brian
[Music]
all right so we have these essential
duck questions that we need to ask but I
guess I want to go back to the beginning
with you Winston because you're a few
weeks younger than me and so I'm just
curious when you came to the Mighty
Ducks franchise because truth be told I
was the perfect age to be affected by
this movie yet I wasn't I remember it
coming out but I also remember feeling
like I had seen other sports movies that
I think I enjoyed more from that like
every every kid needs that Gateway
sports movie that realizes that hey we
can come together on a field or on ice
or on a court to get it get you know
become more than just the sum of our
parts so you have movies like Bad News
Bears you have movies like The Sandlot
The Sandlot I think I loved a lot more
than the Mighty Ducks but the sand lot
was a baseball movie and I played
baseball I never grew up playing hockey
so I guess did you go grow up playing
hockey was that your gateway into the
Mighty Ducks or was it just your movie
Mark I'm gonna be honest with you I I
ain't playing much other than Super
Mario Brothers I kind of was a bump on a
log if you will uh as a matter of fact I
will send this after we're done
recording if you want to intercut this
photo I played so many video games I
actually was on a national circuit and
we're beating like 14 and 15 year olds
at like 10. so like that's that's a true
story Blockbuster did like a national
like competition for like a multitude of
games one of them was Sonic the Hedgehog
and I was just beating the brakes off of
children older than me but to answer
your question
um I played a little bit of street
hockey and only because of these movies
and I and what's funny is
I like look back on it and you know how
most of your childhood is kind of like a
giant like brown out like you remember
really important things that happen to
you but a lot of it just kind of washes
over you I don't fully remember the
first movie minus a couple of funny
scenes the second one is fully imprinted
on my brain and I found myself silently
mouthing the words to the film as it was
going which is insane but I think that's
where my extreme patriotism came from
for a certain period of time and I
everything was a knuckle puck in my mind
every single thing I feel like the the
Tomato Meter on these movies is so low
in part just because let's face it
there's not a lot of 10 year old movie
reviewers out there and so critics are
obviously going to come to this movie
having their own background in sports
movies and inspirational films and quote
kids sports movies and so they've
probably already seen a bunch and so
this does feel reductionist to them but
whereas you and I we'd watch our kid
eyes and you say well this is the first
time I'm seeing this this is the first
time I'm seeing this in a hockey movie
like this movie did make hockey look fun
and it was just a sport that felt
expensive it was a sport that felt like
there were a lot of moving Parts like I
love playing sports as a kid but the ice
skating even the the street hockey the
rollerblades never took to me I could
never keep my bounds and so therefore I
never wanted to play with the other kids
in town didn't really care about playing
hockey so it might just be where you're
from but this movie clearly broke
through and became a cultural Touchstone
it was super profitable the first one
was because it was made for a budget of
like 10 million dollars ended up making
more than 50 million dollars worldwide
and I I guess my rooting interest in
this movie was more closely associated
with the fact that Emilio Estevez plays
a warrior slash now coach Gordon Bombay
I was a huge Young Guns and Young Guns
Too fan at this time so I'm like
anything Billy the Kid is in I'm gonna
support because he's got my boy William
H Bob in there but you know you forget
this is a Disney movie but the premise
is this guy gets a DUI and has to do
community service and that community
service is coaching the kids so it's
kind of an adult theme to kick our
franchise off with bro look I just
recently uh watched the new Pinocchio
and my one beef with that was that do
you remember how dark Disney was Mark
Pinocchio gets turned into a literal ass
because he smokes cigars and drank beer
so so I'm the mini Gordon Bomb Bag is
pulled over for a DUI mounted off to a
cop I was like yeah that checks out so
like I'm not even phased by that
whatsoever I I'm not even phased by the
fact that this man's only punishment was
to teach some kids some hockey most
people get jail time this man was told
na na na na na just go pick up a stick
bruh that'll be fine and it's it's his
backstory incidentally as I'm doing this
from Las Vegas which is just one big
Pleasure Island let's be honest I'm
probably going to turn into an ass at
some point later this afternoon
um you know you you look at the scenes
in this movie that really affected me
and
you know I'm not a huge fan of kids the
the kid actors in this movie are
fantastic you know you get to see a
young Joshua Jackson who's like one of
my doppelgangers for crying out loud but
what I kept coming back to was Amelia
estevez's character because I'd
forgotten when I rewatched this that he
was a youth hockey star and he missed
the shot to win the championship game
and that has affected him so deeply that
he now hates hockey and he can't get
back that love and then you juxtapose
that with the scene where his boss is
just chewing him out and and he gives
him he gives him a give or take and he
starts quacking and I kind of Kyle's
again when Bombay chooses the team over
his job that really really got me Gordon
I'm going to make this simple
are you prepared to lose your job over
some kids some gain
you sir
some kids
some game
collect your personal belongings Gordon
Sir Mr ducksworth
thank you very much Mr ducksworth
quack quack quack quack quack Mr
ducksworth quack quack quack stop quack
quack
quack quack quack quack quack quack
quack quack
you may have paid for this jersey sir
but you didn't earn it
I'll see you in the playoffs yeah I mean
dude it was he starts quacking at him
again that's the part that I think got
me the most can you imagine
quitting your job might be like nah you
want to lie quack quack quack quack
quack quack quack quack and you just
walk all the way out the building
quacking
I am genuinely surprised once again
if not jail this time that this man did
end up in some sort of Psych Ward for
quacking his way out of the building
um but I I think that just goes to show
the power of Youth Hockey you know what
I mean of little league is the fact that
it can completely change your life it
happened in Hardball you know you
mentioned Bad News Bears uh and now here
we are little giants like this is this
is I can't believe I said that name I
hate the Giants so much uh but but
genuinely this movie just is very
far-reaching man that's just what uh
this movie really did and I'm just very
grateful that we got two and a half of
them
two and a half of them so we'll get to
that half in a little bit it feels like
where I was a much bigger fan of the
first Mighty Ducks that you skew more
towards D2 which was a really good
marketing back in the day I can't stress
to y'all how good that marketing was
because it's coming off a Terminator 2
obviously which we just knew was T2 from
92 then this movie comes out in 94 and I
will still say this it may not be my
favorite Mighty Ducks movie Winston the
poster of D2 with the two kids blowing
bubbles at each other as they're about
to do the Face-Off that's one of the
all-time great I'll say it movie posters
in history it is such a cool poster and
it gets butts in seats that movie was
also a big hit I mean I guess you would
say a modest hit but made for the budget
it was it was a very profitable movie
for the Walt Disney Company so why is D2
maybe what should be on the highest
Tomato Meter score for Winston
um there's a number of reasons I mean
one you gotta remember
we're we're in the 90s there's there's
just this ever looming like foreign
threat in our brains constantly so you
give us Iceland and Iceland is just
ruthless they are just trying to rip
people's heads off and they don't give a
damn that immediately like I said where
my blind patriotism kicked in as a child
I was like yeah you're not gonna bully
America yeah like that there's that
element right
um but you added so much to it I I
remember what re-watching it for this
and thinking to myself even though I
just admitted I played some street
hockey when I was a kid
going to the hood and just seeing a
bunch of black kids playing hockey
that's not it's just like not really a
thing like we're just gonna be honest
about it but they needed a way to bring
even more I guess diversity to the squad
obviously you had the uh uh the crew was
pretty like different in their
characters and archetypes and whatnot
but you needed a way to introduce Keenan
in have him talking trash the entire
time who at that point was really his
own star I mean what he was in this and
heavyweights he was in all that Keenan
and Kel was coming soon after I mean you
had this kid that had immeasurable
talents you needed a way to introduce
him
um
but I think finally the thing that's so
important
is it reminds us of the big old adage
don't let money change you and where
you know you had Bombay kind of learned
that lesson in the first one and he
tries to stay true to his guns when he
now has real Fame when he is now the guy
and not some two-bit lawyer but the guy
how it completely changed him and it
took the kids bringing him back
ironically as much as this movie is
about the kids it's almost always about
Gordon uh until we get to the third one
and maybe that's why that one doesn't
hit quite as hard yeah I mean I I feel
like the the adults always learn
something from the kids in these movies
and with the Mighty Ducks too it's
really following the rocky template
where you started out as an underdog and
then you had your shot and then you end
up winning with your in Rocky's case
second shot and then you just let all
the fame and fortune just comes at you
so fast and you start focusing more on
that than you do what got you there
which was Your Love of the Game and your
bond with these kids and with D2 I will
say this the the characters I feel like
getting even more fleshed out because we
know some of these kids from the first
Mighty Ducks but then you also have like
the goalie the back of goalie the cat
she was okay I think is her name she's
so good in that role and then to have
Keenan come in as Russ it really brought
an extra element of like hey not only am
I rooting for Emilio estevez's character
here because he's a million west of us
I'm also rooting for the kids so I might
have felt more of a but like you said
patriotic connection to this team than I
even did the first one because we're
going International now we're fighting
for Stars and Stripes bro I gotta take
it even further and this is proof that
D2 is the the the ultimate of not only
these movies but maybe of all sports
movies the greatest
tag team
of all time in sports
is as far as like productivity maybe not
as like you know some of the most famous
wrestling tag teams or anything like
that but the most the the most profound
tag team is the Splash Brothers out of
the Golden State area I'm talking about
Steph and Clay they didn't make that up
themselves because their balls just go
splash through the hoop sure they did
they did it because I guarantee both
they asses was watching D2 the Mighty
Ducks and they said the bash Brothers
are incredible now I'm not gonna punch
LeBron when I'm on the court but I will
punch him with this ball in his mouth
from the from half court all right
that's what happened they got that
inspiration from this film are you going
on record as saying that the Splash
Brothers named themselves the Splash
Brothers because of D2 absolutely bro
the mighty drunk the Mighty the Mighty
Ducks franchise brought us the Anaheim
Ducks and the Splash Brothers and and
Keenan doing Steve Harvey on SNL what
more do you want
I a Keenan is a star on SNL and and to
see him here I I think that my favorite
part of this though is I love the I love
this stuff with Russ I love the bash
Brothers I was a little disappointed we
didn't get to explore the relationship
the budding relationship in the first
one between Gordon and Charlie's mom
because that would have gotten so
awkward so quickly like it's cute at the
end of a movie to be like oh we might be
falling for each other but then if your
coach is hooking up with your mom it
just it just becomes a sticky situation
so maybe it was best to to check that
baggage and then replace that with these
storylines that really tug in our
heartstrings even more like dude the end
of this movie when when when Julie
pretty much gets knocked out by the puck
and then she opens her glove and drops
the puck revealing that she saved it and
she won the game it's just such a great
that's a it's not a kids movie at that
point for me that becomes an all-time
sports movie moment you might have sold
me on D2 being better than the first one
damn you Winston but dude on top of that
look at some of the other stuff as a
proud Texan you got my boy out here
roping people up but he's also got he's
got literally hockey handles where he's
out here bouncing the puck up and down
like that's incredible again you finally
put the bash Brothers together you get
Kenny Wu Ken Wu out here doing all sorts
of tricks and then pulling the shirt off
that he learned from the black kid in
the neighborhood you know you have to
have the magical uh the black person to
kind of get you through that and teach
you some things like chubs at a you know
Happy Gilmore like all all sorts of just
incredible incredible things going on
there but to that point obviously you
had Connie in the first one and Connie
is still doing stuff here but to have
Julie do this do this at the end of the
film this movie also becomes a feminist
Anthem literally all walks of life get
to fly their flag under the Mighty Ducks
banner and on top of that they were Team
USA fam like I'm trying to tell y'all
this movie is so influential
it was a lot like Home Alone 2 because
now that we knew this universe a little
bit you could open up the world and you
could expand it whereas Home Alone 2
goes to New York and you get some cameos
from some future presidents in that
movie in Mighty Ducks too you had so
many more athlete candidates because the
first one had basil McRae who who was
like a great enforcer uh for a while he
was like one of those like so-called
hockey I wouldn't call him a goon but he
wouldn't take anything and he was on the
team for a reason we'll say yeah yeah
then you all said uh Mike Modano in the
first one let's go that's my guy dude
the second one you get everybody from
Christian Yamaguchi to Kareem
Abdul-Jabbar to Wayne Gretzky yeah the
great one Pops in to D2 and so I think
that there might be even more to chew on
with that one so I mean you could look
at the 21 of the Tomato Meter for D2 and
say well yeah but it's a sequel and
sequels are always a little bit of just
a watered down version of the original I
think this one goes into some different
directions and like you said the
international feel to it I feel like
warrants this movie being much much
higher
absolutely I mean there's
I do get this idea that it can kind of
be watered down a little bit but I would
make the argument that
anything that has kind of has a Trilogy
typically the second one ends up being
the best one if you end the sequel maybe
but if you're doing a true Trilogy like
I mean there are exceptions I'll give
you Return of the Jedi though
universally most people will say Empire
I saw a Return of the Jedi first so that
that one for me but I can admit where I
understand why people say Empire
um The Dark Knight universally people
say that's the best of all of them the
Winter Soldier people universally say
that's the best of all of them like the
second one tends to be that Cornerstone
because it also determines if we're
gonna like we've learned who these
people are we've learned our lessons
from the first let's ramp it up to 11.
it's always sticking to Landing that's
hard and the proof is in the pudding
here honestly
I have moments I really appreciate
knowing where this coach is coming from
by the end of it but I don't appreciate
the fact that he still kind of seems
like a I don't know if I can say the d
word that isn't a duck uh on this show
or not but he's kind of one of those for
most of the film even after we find out
that his daughter got sideswiped and he
he gave up a chance to the NHL for this
though I can I guess sort of understand
it if like you know you would do
anything for your child of course that
doesn't mean you're not upset that your
dreams are like kind of Dash I get why
he's a little angry all the time
um but he's not he's not Gordon man he
just really isn't no no and and so when
we look at the characters that we see
ourselves in
um I I would probably point to Gordon
Bombay more than any kids but you know I
I'd love to say I'm like Charlie Conway
but I'm just I was never that good I was
never a pretty natural Talent at any
sport even though I tried to play all of
them
um The Duncan Brothers uh or excuse me
the Duncans I missed from the first one
that did not make it into the second one
so that was a little bit of a bummer for
me I like the playoff of them but then
having the bash Brothers in there having
the addition of people like Keenan of of
cats uh I felt like that more than made
up for it who is the character that you
wouldson Marshall like me that's me on
the ice right there if you had a fusion
um like a a few either the Fusion Dance
from uh Dragon Ball Z or like uh the way
you would have like a Mexican Asian
fusion restaurant uh if you took Kanan
and you fused him with Charlie that
would be me because Charlie if you
remember he was good enough to be on the
team to make it to the high school but
Charlie wasn't actually very good he
pulled himself out and said no no I'm
more of a coach that's where I kind of
fall in between I got the the the trash
talking and like a crazy shot like the
knuckle Puck I like you if you watch me
play dodgeball and whatnot a lot of
people aren't really ready for like my
sidearm which has a lot of zip to it
comes out of nowhere same way he's like
it's hard to like aim that thing that's
what my sidearm does right and then the
coaching mentality of Charlie where he's
able to come up with plays and stuff
like that that's where I kind of reside
in that area this is just a quick
Sidetrack the movie Dodgeball is is that
accurate to to to dodgeball at all is
that the same style or is it completely
different because like when I was a kid
dodgeball there was one ball and you
just kept throwing it until everybody
was out
yes and no I mean I won't lie it
definitely gets annoying every time
someone hears you play dodgeball like if
you dodge a wrench yeah okay all right
sure
um so to a certain extent but obviously
they like kind of had their fun with
that and they wanted to make sure that
the comedy was there but there have been
plenty of teams that I've been on where
we have been in full costume uh not BDSM
you know leather daddy costumes but like
the way you had like uh the skills that
killed the dudes in the track suits and
all that we've done stuff before like
I've played an entire Halloween
tournament where I was Batman we had the
Justice League so I was Batman out of
Robin there was a green arrow someone
came as Wonder Woman Like it was pretty
legit uh in that regard and I love
playing in the weho DodgeBall League
because costumes is like the whole thing
like one time it was Heroes and when I
tell you that like 9 out of 10 of the
individuals there came dressed as Sailor
Moon or Wonder Woman it was phenomenal
it was just so much fun to watch
so great yeah we all got to get to uh
get to go see Winston and you know you
talk about uh the the fusion of
characters in this movie it's
interesting when you look at these
websites that have now sprung up all
these facts you didn't know about the
Mighty Ducks and all these different
things because everything from Bleach
report to ESPN from all these
entertainment Outlets have oh did you
know this about the Mighty Ducks so it
clearly made its way into the cultural
Zeitgeist somehow how much of that do
you think is due to the movies
themselves or the fact that it did spawn
an NHL franchise a little column a
little column B I mean again I mentioned
earlier the Splash Brothers like how
that directly influenced them but the
fact that that this was a move
to for like they were already planning
this NHL team and then it got so much
fire they could really use it to push it
over the edge I mean I think that that's
incredible and I don't know many movies
period that have done that I'm genuinely
trying to think and maybe you you can
come up with something Mark I don't know
many movies that then turned out a major
thing other than an amusement park you
know what I mean no I mean Tim had a
pretty comprehensive list and I will say
that I back him up fully with the
Toronto Raptors because that was totally
Jurassic Park you know why because
nobody knew what the hell a raptor was
until Jurassic Park came out nobody knew
I was a kid of web dinosaurs all right I
was 13 when Jurassic Park came out
nobody knew what the hell a velociraptor
was we just assumed Spielberg made it up
because he's a genius when it comes to
creativity and Imagination so the
Toronto Raptors fully have to thank
Jurassic Park and I love that their
outdoor area is called Jurassic Park but
here here's my hot take on this is it I
think that the hockey team the actual
NHL team great they ended up winning a
championship later no impact on the
longevity of the Mighty Ducks movie I
feel like that Mighty Ducks movie and
the movie franchise would still stand
having said that
um the prevailing logic is that back in
the day a sequel to The Mighty Ducks was
not initially planned but they already
had the team in the works and so Michael
Eisner saw it as an opportunity to sort
of cross promote and he's like well
we'll have the movie come out that's why
that that Poster's so good that's why
that marketing campaign was so prevalent
because D2 and you had the team and so I
do give a tip of the cap to the team but
I still say these movies stand on their
own and then we get to the third one for
you does it fall off a cliff or is it
just not quite as good because we don't
have Coach Bombay anymore
um
but I think Bombay has a lot to do with
it I appreciate where he comes in to
protect their scholarships and gives
them advice to Charlie because Charlie's
getting unruly I don't know if it's if
Emilio was just busy scheduling wise so
they were like you got me for 10 pages
15 pages of the script but I got other
things to do uh
but I do think it lost a lot it was
always the balance between the coach and
the kids and so to put
80 90 of the movie on the kids now
there was a weird element kind of lost
that wasn't what we originally signed up
for I guess you know what I'm saying I'm
not saying you can't change formats but
something got lost in translation for
sure yeah and you know you think back on
these two film franchises when you pair
a sibling rivalry between the two Mighty
Ducks movie the first two Mighty Ducks
movies and the first two major league
movies where you have Charlie Sheen in
Major League versus Emilio Estevez in
the Mighty Ducks I'm probably leaning
towards Major League just because I love
that first one but the sequel to Major
League is nowhere near as good as the
first one where I feel like D2 you might
have won me over is better than the
first one do you take Mighty Ducks over
major league in the Estevez Sheen War
absolutely and it's funny you say a few
weeks you mean like
200 something weeks as far as like our
age Gap there so the difference is with
the difference with major league is like
it is about adults so like you know what
I'm saying like uh people that are that
are skewing a little bit older and not
like old I'm not calling you old I'm
just saying that like you're like older
than me
um you're gonna like something like that
whereas a kid if I could see myself in
the same way that like three ninjas or
uh um Surf Ninjas really any ninja film
with children I would be like yo that's
the thing and this is just ninjas on Ice
that's it or ninjas in the sewer because
you also have those turtles that are
turtles ninja turtles yeah I was a Big
Surf Ninjas guy was a big three ninjas
guy by the time they had high noon at
Magic Mountain or whatever I was already
out of the Gathering I was so out
and I think we were both out on D3 and
so our ranking I'll I think I'll amend
mine I think I'll go D2 as my top and
then I'll go the Mighty Ducks the
original at number two and then I will
go D3 at a far cry I think you do what
you can if you don't have Emilio back
and you make Charlie sort of now to
Mentor like I understand where they're
going with that but I will give the
Mighty Ducks franchise credit they
helped launch the career of one Joshua
Jackson who went on to do Dawson's Creek
do you know that Leonardo DiCaprio also
auditioned for the role of Charlie and
didn't get it it went to Jackson Jake
Gyllenhaal was also in the conversation
but Jake Gyllenhaal apparently his
parents wouldn't let him take the role
that's kind of crazy he could have been
on Dawson's Creek could have been on
Dawson's Creek could have been could
have been I think it worked out okay for
Jake but here's I guess okay you know
they hear something that's even crazier
is it the the actors considered for the
role of Gordon Bombay were none other
than Charlie Sheen Bill Murray Tom
Cruise Tom Hanks and Michael J fox so I
give you that list Winston we're going
to take Billy the Kid out of the
equation let's say that Amelia was off
doing Young Guns three so he couldn't
make the Mighty Ducks who is your Gordon
Bombay if those are my options
I think
I don't hate Charlie Sheen because
Charlie and Emilio have a very similar
energy they kind of diverge at a certain
point but they do have a certain similar
energy but I think I'm probably going
Michael J fox because I don't think
we've ever seen him play
um you know that d word that's not duck
uh you know and so
it would have been interesting to see
that you know what I mean and I think he
would have related to the kids so much
because he himself real I mean I know
every a lot of like Tom Cruise was a
young star but but Michael J fox I mean
you know what I'm saying we're sitting
here talking about Back to the Future
and whatnot I think it would have been
really interesting to see him kind of
lead the new wave of kids that were
meant to be Superstars and he's Canadian
and he plays hockey so he's perfect he's
my pick as well I was so happy he took
Michael J fox because he not only can
play Ice Hockey but I think that you
talk about the d word he also was
another d word doc as in Doc How would
Doc Hollywood and in that movie he's
sort of a fish out of water doesn't want
to be in this small town it ends up
taken to it so I think that's a similar
energy you could bring to it I could see
Michael J fox being sort of a statinos
preppy lawyer who is just trying to get
out of whatever white collar crime he
committed whatever DUI he might have
gotten and then this is what we end up
with so Michael J fox I wouldn't trade
Emilio for anybody but if we had to lose
lose him I would say Michael J fox
pretty good pickup absolutely man I
think he would have been he would have
absolutely killed it yeah and then um
here's a fun fact too the uh that kiss
scene that they film in the first one
between uh Gordon Bombay and Charlie's
mom it's Emilio Estevez and I think it's
Heidi Klang they it was actually filmed
in Minnesota and during that first kiss
it was so cold that their lips touch and
then their lips got Frozen together
their wish got Frozen together and so
the makeup team had to spray some
lukewarm water on them to get their lips
to separate because it was like a dumb
and dumber situation when you lit the
pole and then your tongue gets stuck
there so their lips actually got stuck
together that is that's an all-time
movie fact for me
it was so cold there was like the guy
have you ever kissed someone and it was
so cold your lips got stuck together
Winston Martin hell no I'm from Texas I
ain't going to no damn cold ass State
let my lipstick no
no that's that I saw Dumb and Dumber a
million times I that was enough for me I
was like no thank you no no no no no no
do you have a favorite sports movie
romance because if I'm looking and I'm
gonna open this up to all the sports
movies uh listeners and viewers of this
show no I Love My White Men Can't Jump
so I love the relationship between Billy
Hoyle and Gloria Rosie Perez in that
movie
um then there's ones that just feel like
eh the natural never dated for me I
never bought into Robert Redford with
either uh Glenn Close with Kim Basinger
until you know that whole thing went
South I just never bought the love in
there when I watched natural I'm just
there for the home run at the end that's
all I really need and Wilford brimley's
amazing chest hair
um then you have the just these awkward
kind of like Barbara Hershey and
Hoosiers where it's like I don't know
her Gene Hackman I don't really feel
that there's a chemist but maybe we're
just like two adults who just like
playing bridge together so where do you
where do you rank Charlie's mom and
Gordon and what is the best sports movie
relationship of all time
I mean I had mentioned the film before I
would put Charlie's mom and
um
you know and and Gordon below
uh Keanu and Diane from Hardball uh I
thought that that was a that was a good
little little romance flare up there I
gotta say it's gonna sound wild but I
think my favorite sports movie romance
of all time
has to once again be Keanu as Shane
Falco and the head cheerleader in The
Replacements there was there they they
had Every Breath You Take in the bar
he's like Shane he's at the 10. he's at
the five oh it's a touchdown I was like
yo that's actually kind of cute and hot
at the same time like that's that was
that was that was like a moment that
sticks in my brain uh that they really
nailed the sports element to uh the
hookup so it was that that's got to be
my best one and you are lodged firmly in
my brain because I was watching uh the
TV here in the hotel uh first night I
was in Vegas The Replacements came on so
naturally I watched the whole thing and
I loved that scene in the bar when he
kisses her because that is going through
my head and I imagine most most guys who
are sports fans that's what's going in
our head when we go in to make that
first move is you have your announcers
and in my case it is Pat Summerall and
John Madden that are commentating on the
action anytime I'm on a date I do have
announcers in my head the whole time for
any future romantic the conquest of Mark
Ellis there are announcers in my head
and a stadium full of people the entire
time we're going out to dinner just so
you know dude sadly minor Troy or Troy
Aikman and Joe Buck and Joe Buck just in
my head just is is so frustrating like
it's it's not something that you want
man no no sometimes sometimes you got to
turn that off a little bit but you know
sometimes you need it and to quote a
great hockey call of all time Al
Michael's saying do you believe in
miracles Ellis gets a second date so
that is going to be all for our movie
talk here on the Mighty Ducks franchise
but the last word goes to Winston
Marshall is there a quote from a Mighty
Duck film that you find yourself
referring back to again and again are
you quacking around the house uh I also
love him not a girl I'm a duck I love
that they're just it's just such a movie
about Unity what is your Mighty Ducks
quote if you have one stick gloves shirt
I I like like real talk it's funny I I
it sounds like like I'm joking and I
sort of am but I'm not because I was
that kid that was getting bullied when I
was growing up man so like the idea that
it wasn't necessarily having to get to a
fight but if you could just intimidate
or confuse your opponent in that regard
and and that was the thing Ken was the
smallest one on the team he was a figure
skater and he learned again from the
chubs of the film uh Russ's older
brother to like how to how to punk
somebody if you need to do it I I just
thought that that was such a cool moment
of
you know seeing that of seeing someone
who's in their shell defend themselves
and he became the littlest bash brother
out of it you know so I'm right there
with that one that's got to be a stick
gloves shirt I'm gonna get you come here
come here come here come here okay I'll
just mess with you okay listen when a
guy comes at you like I just did you do
this
gloves and shirt
okay yeah okay my turn stick
gloves
sure
all right all right
that's right unlike Jose Canseco and
Mark Maguire's bash Brothers I feel like
these bash Brothers might have passed a
steroid test so let's uh we don't have a
mailbag today but Brian go ahead and hit
some outro music for us just to wake
everyone up
[Music]
always a great time here on Rotten
Tomatoes is wrong when I'm down to
Jacqueline Coley this week but I got up
a Winston Marshall Winston it's always
good to spend time with you on or off
camera my man so I know you have some
new stuff brewing and and this capes and
cows thing is really fascinating because
I am not necessarily the purveyor I used
to be of content online but to watch you
and Christian and koi kind of chew the
fat and let's face it to watch you and
koi kind of teach Christian about the
modern comic book Canon it's like you're
teaching me as well hey Christian and I
talk about all the time without folks
like you and koi in the world we would
be lost in the current phases of the MCU
in DC whatever they're calling it now
there's a lot of stuff there's a lot of
work that goes into it so thank you for
being there to teach folks like
Christian and I what's going on can I
ask you a question though you know who
Meg the stallion is right I do know who
Meg the stallion is and I fully endorse
any twerking that happens on She-Hulk
because you know that your your better
half had no idea he thought that she was
a made-up character for She-Hulk
oh I gotta talk to Dad
I'm gonna have to give him a call or
maybe he'll prefer a telegram I'm not
sure how to get in touch maybe I'll send
him a postcard
um the dearest Christian
I've missed too low these many weeks but
I've been following Meg the stallion's
career yeah we'll have to have a chat
with him but that's why you're there
that's why you are there and Coy is
there for capes and cows so where can
everybody find that show Absolutely so
if you go to the Christian heart love
Channel you'll see uh capes and cows I
also do uh you know reviews and uh soon
to be doing um some other really cool
interview stuff over there as well uh
but if you want to follow me man please
I'm the Swaggy blurred anyway the Swaggy
blurs has sold Twitter Instagram uh but
the two main focus or the three main
focuses right now are Tick Tock twitch
and YouTube uh over on my uh Tick Tock
you can see uh short comedy bits as well
as some motivational stuff uh on my
YouTube You'll see Full comedy sketches
uh some of them dropping uh very early
next month uh or I don't know what day
we recorded this to drop but you don't
want to miss that uh for sure got a lot
of really funny stuff uh on there and
then finally over on Twitch uh you know
I will break down
uh the news of the day whether it be the
internet or politics or whatever else
while screaming at somebody uh playing
either Halo or Skyrim or whatever it is
I feel is my inkling at the time so come
and hang out with me man I am active
seven days a week on one of those
platforms uh and the easiest way to find
out where obviously I will tell you on
Twitter but the Swaggy blurred across
the board that's where you can find me
you see that for all you youth hockey
players out there for All You Youth
dodgeball kickball players for all the
Utes out there if you do what you love
you never work a day in your life and
Winston Marshall working as hard as
anyone but enjoying the process so thank
you for being here today
um do you have like a movie or TV
recommendation something you're
currently watching that you're like oh
everybody needs to be checking this out
um I mean a lot of it is going to be
stuff that people are already watching
uh you know big fan of House of the
Dragon She-Hulk uh you know the stuff
like that
um
if you're an adult watching this show
uh if you uh are into this sort of thing
there's this great show on Netflix
called how to build a sex room it's kind
of great it's absolutely hilarious and
amazing you should check that out I feel
like y'all would really really enjoy
that
um uh yeah and P Valley over on Stars
always love giving a shout out to pee
Valley it's a great show as well but
also for adults no no Mighty Ducks here
please yeah we certainly dropped that
kids movie Motif pretty quick
that is uh the wonderful the one the
only the Swaggy board Winston Marshall I
am merely Mark Ellis for the whole team
here at Rotten Tomatoes thank you so
much for joining us week in and week out
you can email us anytime and mailbag
we'll be back next week so hit us up RT
is wrong at rottentomatoes.com with your
take on what movies we have talked about
or what we should be talking about we
always love suggestions like we got for
this show thanks to our fresh member of
the ketchup crew Robert drost and and uh
you can also rate review wherever you're
enjoying this however you do so whatever
that platform encourages you to do with
your favorite podcast please do that for
us and share it with your friends for
Lucy for our expert engineer Brian Perez
the whole team here at Rotten Tomatoes
Jacqueline Coley my beloved co-host and
Winston Marshall our special guest today
Gordon Bombay the bash Brothers
everybody involved with the Mighty Ducks
who by the way won a championship the
year after Disney sold him Disney sold
them and then they won the Stanley Cup
fun fact that's gonna do it for this
week I am Mark Ellis for Rotten Tomatoes
is wrong saying ducks fly it again
foreign
[Music]
[Music]